[Music]
i come from a family of
six children and i was the oldest
yeah in between us there was a brother
ryan and after me my mother had twins
but uh one of them died her name was
freda
then is tuted and a little brother yanka
and we lived a very happy life my father
was a businessman
and we were educated in chechiton in
yiddish we had a yeshiva in the town
that we supported
we never experienced any anti-semitism
under the czech government
we associated my friends were czech
you know so we had a very happy home
[Music]
life
the hungarian army came in and then they
occupied the cafe
they took our business away they just
plain blind came in and they occupied
them
and they told you get out and that was
it
[Music]
there was like rumbling uh rows of tanks
were coming through the town and they
parked those things
in the center and we heard those noises
during the night
in the morning there was a knock on our
door and there were two assassins
standing
and he said let's go
towards the end they started to
liquidate the ghetto
they started to ship people out event
like they ship animals you know those
open trains
they never opened up the cars it never
stopped
it just constantly was going
and we were suffocated practically there
and because there were so many people
crammed into a small place there was no
water people were fainting elderly
people were dying
and finally after three days of
traveling
the train suddenly stopped and suddenly
opened up the doors
and i heard they say that man here this
goes here the people started yeah
they didn't know there was going with
those rubber sticks you know here there
and we were very scared and we didn't
know nothing i remember my father was
grabbed my brother you know and my
mother the foot of the five the five
kids my mother and me my sister
we were holding together and as we come
down they were the ss pushed my father
here
and we go here and my mother
was going with me with my sister and
there was eight ten
eleven they pushed it here and i
remember my my mother the kids thought
hi mommy mommy you know and my mother
pulled herself away from me and she says
[ __ ]
you should take care of your sister like
a viewer the minute we stepped off the
freight train we were separated right
there and then
my father and my older brother went on
one side
my sister she was a tall girl so they
made her go to one side and i went with
my mother
and with the uh younger children
and my mother looked around and she says
well where's
your sister i said they made her go over
there so she tells me
you run after her because she only has
one dress on her and they pushed her on
one side and i was running
from one place to another and i don't
know how
because in auschwitz you just did not
run from one place to another
but somehow i caught up with her and
i found her and we were marching
you know they took us into a section
where all the women
arrivals came in and that was a big
long barrett and you stay there
we were in auschwitz for three days in
barracks
and outside all that going down there
was a big band
playing music constantly day and night
there was
smoke heavy smoke there were babies
screaming you people looking where it's
come from
but you couldn't see where it's come
from everybody was screaming and crying
and running
and and they said you know don't cry
you'll be after they go
shower and they'll you'll meet them an
afternoon they'll meet again yes since
then that was the last time we started
my father my brother my grandmother my
mother
and my younger brother that was the last
time i've seen them
i had never heard of anything about my
rest of the family until one day i was
sitting by the window i was mending the
socks
and this friend of mine walks into the
room and he said to me
yeah sylvia what are you going to give
me i have a surprise for you
and i picked up my head and i saw my
sister standing in the yard you know in
the courtyard
so first i thought i was seeing things
and then she gave a yell and i ran out
in the courtyard
and we both fainted right there in the
[Music]
spot
[Music]
i attended a jewish school audacious oil
and berliners did my sister
most of the time we were very aware of
the fact that we live in dangerous times
on cornedor before we went to synagogue
it's the custom for father to bless his
children
and i remember all the years that i can
think back that when my father blessed
my sister and me
he always cried and i assumed
that it was
because they knew
small as you were you you realized that
and of course we were confronted daily
daily
with the swastika and the
hordes and in the glass cases on the
street corners
the display of the sturmer
my father would sometimes pick one up in
a train and bring it home
so there was this feeling of
an impending doom
[Music]
he was taken away very early in the
morning my mother was crying and
there was such to do that my sister and
i woke up and we went to see what was
going on
and i remember the policeman saying as
far as he knows
that they're being deported
to poland and um that's
the last time i saw my father
when castaner came it was a disaster
and it became clear that life for jews
in germany was
all over
decisions had to be made as to who
should go
and who should not go for example
uh one of my uncles and decided not to
send both of their children they would
send one child to test the waters
and keep one child with them
to see if this would work because there
was no certainty it was
actually fought with danger and we're
made aware of the fact that we will be
carrying a luggage tag in our lapel and
all it would say
is the name and the district and
building which we live no street
nothing else no identity and that we
were to act as though we didn't know
from where we came
we left in the morning early in the
morning it was time so that we would get
to the border at night
because we needed the cover of darkness
of course i remember leaving from
barnhuft saw
and i remember that not about a minute
or two out of bonhoeffer
on the elevated tracks of the railroad
came into view the hull
of this burned and destroyed famous
synagogue of berlin fazan strasse
and that was the last
stab in the heart for a little jewish
boy
to see the burnt hulk of this
famous synagogue
i also remember very well that my mother
took me into a corner in this railroad
compartment
i remember well what she said to me
in order to make sure i understood
because of course i was a little boy
very attached to my mother it was a
great love
relationship in that
little speech in the train
i always say i became bar mitzvah i have
not been formally my mitzvah when i was
13 i was not balanced but
i was permissed when i was 11 by my
mother
no menu no rabbi i was given my my
orders my commandments
as to what to do and i remember that
i was to be the hero of the family and
toughest design to be courageous
and so the journey took it took its last
hour or two
at the station as we got off the train
uh my mother said to me you must not try
you must turn must not turn around
and look back and you must not cry and
she did not kiss me good luck goodbye
because there was just no time
we took we went to the left we chilled
and i remember my mother and the other
lady turned to the light
and that was the last we saw them that
was december 6
1938 in the middle of the night
[Music]
i remember having to go to a
photographer
in jorge fein to have pictures taken i
still have those pictures
in the little dutch folder at home and
we got to england and that was of course
the last i saw my sister who
unfortunately perished in bergen-belsen
[Music]
[Music]
i was living with my family my father
mother
and a brother who was five years younger
i went to school we were living a life
of wonderful
affluence and happiness we went skiing
in the winter swimming in the summer
this is my brother and myself
my jewishness was more mostly combined
with sports
and we we went friday night sometimes
into the synagogue but it was more of an
onyx shabbat kind of thing we i know we
drove with the car to the synagogue
[Music]
you lost your childhood i think at that
moment
you suddenly were wearing a star and you
were not allowed to be in a tram
sitting with other people you had to be
standing on one of the outside places
very similar to discrimination in this
country where the blacks were
pushed to the side
[Music]
in teresa at one point they were testing
some
vaccine against scarlet fever
so people were sick then they were
trying to
to get some vaccine for jaundice i was
laying in bed with my brother
that had an enormous jaundice and my
mother had
very dangerous scarlet fever she was
burning up with enormous fever
[Music]
it was freezing it was muddy they didn't
let people go to the bathroom
and people had to relieve themselves
while they were standing with tears in
their eyes
i remember one incident my brothers
telling my mother that he was hungry and
she had nothing to give him and she was
crying and
that was certainly enough for me never
to mention
anything anything at all
my mother said now i was at that point
almost 14 she said you are gonna tell
them you are 18
and you volunteer and you go and you
you go with the rest of the women
i will stay with my brother and my
explanation was
that she has to stay with my brother
because he would forget his name
and i must admit that i was
very angry at my mother for a very very
long
time that she didn't save herself
for me i passed through the
selection i was now selected to go
to germany to work and i suddenly see
that there was somebody they were
examining
women and somebody got up from the table
and
she was bleeding and i lost it i started
to cry i went back to my mommy
and they couldn't quiet me down and a
and a german lady
a guard came over to me and asked me
why are you crying and i spoke
very nicely german and i said i want to
go back to my mommy
she took me to her room and
she gave me cocoa which i didn't see for
years and years and years
and she says to me now i will tell you
something
and please listen to me don't cry
and don't try to get back to your
parents you are better off you are here
with
women that know you they speak the same
language
and you're going out into germany you're
gonna you're getting
out of here she really
saved my life
and then i found out later that my
mother was my little brother they went
to the gas
chambers the next day the moment we
left the the men left
then the women left for hard labor to go
to germany
they took their older and the women with
the children
and they guessed them
[Music]
my father's name was irvin bloch my
mother
was marca and i had a brother george
both my grandparents were farmers which
was quite unusual for a jewish family
both
of my grandparents had farms and my
parents grew up there i remember my
grandmother very well she was
gorgeous her white hair very lovely
and she was killed when she was
86 years old by the germans
[Music]
there was very little food the birth was
very dreadfully hard
and then it was completely closed
[Music]
it was so claustrophobic and there was
absolutely
uh not enough food for me a lot was
especially
horrible because of the children they
cried and cried and then
they stopped crying one day
they executed i don't know how many
people because i never
had the courage to go and look they let
them
hang on the square for several days
my mother went there because she said
someone
has to pray for them
from time to time the germans came and
they took people away
[Music]
the germans went from
one place to the other and then they let
us go
in the street and there was this always
officer a german officer
who said this person goes this way and
this
person goes back and they took all the
old people and the children and took
them away
[Music]
we went out of the train and they
right there they started dividing women
from men and
i only could see my father's face and he
said
take care of mother and that was all and
i was
you know i didn't see him walking away
it was just
such a crowd you see and
we worked a hand in hand with my mother
and there was a mengele and he showed my
mother
to the right side and took and i wanted
to go with her
and there was a soldier and he threw me
to the ground and said you stay here
that would write these people going
what's going to happen to them
and he said don't be hysterical and if
you ask you're going to see them again
very vividly i can i can see
pictures like in a movie you know i can
see
details but i have there is no
connection
and the last
uh night um
i i don't think i spoke to anybody the
whole time i was in amsterdam i just
lost all uh capability of community
communicating with people and i sort of
crawled aside
and i thought my mother and i couldn't
think about anything except my mother
my mama i don't remember
sitting on the ground and i held up my
hand and there was this victim you know
the dandelions
and it came to me and it landed on my
hand and i thought my
mother she's here i think maybe she just
died that moment
[Music]
you